This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Ideas for magazine design that will blow his mind. Best, cover, ever. Finally, our guide to what readers want. You know the same. You can't judge a book by its cover. With magazines, it's pretty much the opposite. That's Avery Chouffleman. She works here. You can and you should judge a magazine by its cover.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。杂志设计的创意会让他大开眼界。史上最棒的封面。最后，我们带你了解读者想要什么。你知道那句老话。人不可貌相。但对于杂志来说，情况恰恰相反。那是埃弗里·乔夫曼。她在这里工作。你可以而且应该通过封面来评判一本杂志。
The story behind the cover that everyone is talking about. They want you to. Change your cover, change your life. The cover of the magazine is the unified identity for a whole host of ideas and authors and designers who have created the eclectic array of stories and articles and materials within each issue. And some would argue this identity extends to the reader as well. Magazine covers are very potent. So if you're holding a copy of Vogue, in the moment that you're seen with that, either by yourself or by your peers, then you are a Vogue reader. And this is different than being a Twilight reader or a DaVinci code reader.
每个人都在谈论的封面背后的故事。他们希望你这么做。改变你的封面，改变你的人生。杂志的封面是一个统一的标志，代表着无数的思想、作者和设计师，他们创造了每一期中形形色色、异彩纷呈的故事、文章和材料。有些人会认为，这种标志也延伸到了读者身上。杂志封面极具感染力。所以，如果你手里拿着一本《Vogue》，在你被自己或同龄人看到拿着它的那一刻起，你就是《Vogue》的读者。这与成为《暮光之城》读者或《达芬奇密码》读者是不同的。
A book is a fixed moment in time, whereas a magazine is a constant source of ever-changing content. And that's where the design of a magazine is so challenging. Learn how this old publication got a fresh new look. Magazine covers are a composition of text and visuals that are designed to express a specific identity month after month or a week after week. You've got the logo, you've got the photograph, you've got color, you've got words. The secrets of magazine design, our expert, reveals all. This is Andy. My name is Andy Kells, I blog at coverthing.com, which is a blog all about covers.
书籍是时间中定格的瞬间，而杂志则是不断变化的内容的源泉。这就是杂志设计极具挑战性的原因。了解这份老牌刊物如何焕然一新。杂志封面是文本和视觉效果的组合，旨在月复一月或周复一周地表达特定的身份。你有标志、照片、颜色和文字。杂志设计的秘密，我们的专家将一一揭晓。这是安迪。我叫安迪·凯尔斯，我在coverthing.com写博客，这是一个专门关于封面的博客。
He also worked in Creative at Marie Claire, Rolling Stone, and a whole bunch of other magazines, both in the United States and England. So we know as a thing or two about covers. Starting from the top, literally, because that's where the name of the magazine always is. When you see a magazine, the first thing you're asking the readers to do is just identify the brand. That's central.
他还曾在《嘉人》、《滚石》以及美国和英国的一大批其他杂志的创意部门工作过。所以我们知道他对封面略知一二。从头开始，字面意义上的，因为杂志的名字总是在那里。当你看到一本杂志时，你首先要求读者做的事情就是识别品牌。这是核心。
If that doesn't happen, everything else fails. And then you've got to show them that this is the new issue, the one they don't have yet. I think the best way to do this is with color. The reader might think, oh, the last one, if I recall, was green. This one is blue, so clearly it's different. Then the photograph. Photograph is the thing that creates a really powerful emotional connection with the reader.
如果没有做到这一点，其他一切都会失败。然后你必须向他们展示这是新一期，是他们还没有的那一期。我认为做到这一点的最好方法是通过颜色。读者可能会想，哦，我记得上一期是绿色的。这一期是蓝色的，所以显然它不同。然后是照片。照片是与读者建立真正强烈的精神共鸣的东西。
You see somebody, you see the eye contact, you recognise them as celebrities. It's a very high level of engagement. But the photograph wasn't always part of the equation. The early magazine covers were essentially illustrated. So you're looking at Norman Rockwell, you're looking at the amazing art that was on the cover of though, Harpers. You're looking at paintings and drawings. And he had a few examples on hand, like this one. Man's action, which has a red-headed woman in a short dress and what appears to be a
你看到某人，你看到了眼神交流，你认出他们是名人。这是非常高级的互动。但照片并不总是等式的一部分。早期的杂志封面基本上都是插图。所以你看诺曼·洛克威尔，你看那些曾经出现在《哈珀斯》封面上的精美艺术品。你看的是绘画和素描。他手头有几个例子，比如这个。男人杂志，上面有一个穿短裙的红发女人和一个看起来像
bodice tied to some sort of Indian totem pole. But these are paintings. Illustrated, like old movie posters. These are not celebrities. These are just paintings of scenes that might appear in the 60s man's fantasy. Men of the 60s were very imaginative.
绑在某种印第安图腾柱上的胸衣。但这些都是画作。有插图的，就像旧电影海报一样。这些不是名人。这些只是一些可能出现在60年代男人幻想中的场景的画作。60年代的男人们非常有想象力。
And beyond the men's magazines, a lot of major publications actually had cartoon mascots on the cover. Some of them persist today, like the Playboy Bunny, mad magazines, Alfred E. Newman, and the mascot of the New Yorker, the monocled Eustace Tilly. Even UK Vogue had an illustrated mascot, Ms. Exeter, an elegant 50-something woman who had an advice column about being a classy, classy name. An Esquire had Eski, a moust mustachioed skirt chaser in a fedora. And a lot of Esquire covers featured him. Until George Lois came along.
除了男士杂志，许多主要刊物实际上还在封面上印有卡通吉祥物。其中一些延续到了今天，比如花花公子兔，疯狂杂志的阿尔弗雷德·E·纽曼，以及《纽约客》的吉祥物——戴单片眼镜的尤斯蒂斯·蒂利。甚至英国版的《Vogue》也有一个带插图的吉祥物，埃克塞特女士，一个优雅的50多岁女性，她有一个专栏，专门提供关于如何成为一个有品位的人的建议，真是个有品位的名字。而《时尚先生》则有埃斯基，一个戴着软呢帽、留着小胡子的花花公子。许多《时尚先生》的封面都以他为特色。直到乔治·洛伊斯出现。
George Lois was the pioneer in the industry. He was the guy who made magazine covers sexy. He revolutionized the cover of Esquire using big bold eye catching photographs. You've probably seen some of these covers, or at least homages to them. He did one of Richard Nixon getting makeup put on him, one of Ed Sullivan wearing a Beatles wig. He did one of a beautiful woman shaving her face and a man putting on lipstick. For the 60s, these were shocking.
乔治·洛伊斯是这个行业的先驱。他是那个让杂志封面变得性感的人。他通过使用大胆、引人注目的照片，彻底革新了《时尚先生》的封面。你可能见过其中的一些封面，或者至少见过对它们的致敬。他做过一张理查德·尼克松被化妆的照片，一张埃德·沙利文戴着披头士假发的照片。他还做过一张美丽的女人刮脸和一个男人涂口红的照片。对于60年代来说，这些都是令人震惊的。
Shocking. No more cartoon covers. The crazy thing was that Lois didn't even work for Esquire. My name is George Lois and I never had a role at Esquire. He was an admin. He was behind a lot of the most famous ads of all time. Iconic 60s posters for American Airlines, Xerox, and even political campaigns for candidates like Robert Kennedy and Ed Koch.
令人震惊。不再有卡通封面。最疯狂的是，洛伊斯甚至不是《时尚先生》的员工。我叫乔治·洛伊斯，我从未在《时尚先生》担任过职务。他是个行政人员。他曾参与制作了许多有史以来最著名的广告。美国航空、施乐的标志性60年代海报，甚至还有罗伯特·肯尼迪和埃德·科奇等候选人的政治竞选海报。
Many people who written about the covers called me the author of the Oscar. I was never the author of the Oscar. I just did that covers. In 1962, Harold Hayes, head editor of Esquire magazine, asked Lois to do a cover for him. And as Lois tells the story, Hayes needed a cover from him in three days. You know, he gave me a description of, you know,
许多写过关于这些封面的人称我为奥斯卡的创作者。我从来都不是奥斯卡的创作者。我只是做了这些封面。1962年，《时尚先生》杂志的主编哈罗德·海耶斯请洛伊斯为他做一个封面。正如洛伊斯所讲的故事，海耶斯需要在三天内从他那里得到一个封面。你知道，他给了我一个描述，你知道，
20 things in the magazine. And then he said, oh yeah, I went to one of the spread. We have a photograph of Floyd Patterson, the photograph of the sonny list. Floyd Patterson versus Sonny Liston. This was the upcoming heavyweight fight. The issue was going to come out before the fight and everyone was predicting that Patterson would win.
杂志里的20件事。然后他说，哦对了，我想要其中一个跨页。我们有一张弗洛伊德·帕特森的照片，一张桑尼·利斯顿的照片。弗洛伊德·帕特森对阵桑尼·利斯顿。这是一场即将到来的重量级比赛。这一期将在比赛前出版，每个人都预测帕特森会赢。
And Lois did a really gutsy thing. Three days later, I delivered them a cover where I showed somebody looked like Floyd Patterson did a really gutsy thing. So there's a good chance that Esquire would be wrong. And this could make the magazine look really bad. So bad. Can you imagine a major publication that predicted the wrong outcome of a huge heavyweight fight? Oh my god, so embarrassing. But Harold Hayes, the editor of Esquare, went along with it, and Lois actually called it.
而洛伊斯做了一件非常勇敢的事。三天后，我交出了一个封面，上面显示有一个人看起来像弗洛伊德·帕特森，做了一件非常勇敢的事。所以《时尚先生》很有可能会猜错。这可能会让杂志看起来很糟糕。太糟了。你能想象一个主要刊物预测了一场大型重量级比赛的结果却错了会怎样吗？哦，天哪，太尴尬了。但《时尚先生》的编辑哈罗德·海耶斯顺从了，而洛伊斯实际上预言对了。
So in any way, the point is that Paterson got knocked out of every FCA stream, and everybody in America went crazy over the next 400 sold an extra 400,000 copies, at 400,000 copies, on a new stand. I think they would have sold 800,000, how do you get it wrong? And they did cover for the next 19 years. Lois went on to create a catalog of 92 Esquire covers. Most of them just as eye-catching and controversial
不管怎样，重点是帕特森被击倒了，全美国的人都为之疯狂，在报摊上多卖了40万册，40万册。我认为他们本可以卖出8万册，你怎么能弄错呢？他们接下来的19年里都负责做封面。洛伊斯继续创作了92个《时尚先生》封面的目录。其中大多数和他的第一个封面一样引人注目且充满争议。
as his first. I think that because Joseloyas was like an ad guy, he was able to see the potential of the brand with the widest possible vision. And he was he who ushered in this age of magazine covers, bitning, or sort of a powerful presentation of an idea more than just what happened to be in the magazine.
我认为，因为乔治·洛伊斯就像一个广告人，他能够以最广阔的视野看到这个品牌的潜力。正是他迎来了杂志封面的这个时代，比起仅仅发生在那本杂志里的内容，这是一种对思想的强有力呈现。
One big, stark image with little or no text. They look almost like wall posters. And now, many of them are in the permanent collection in the Museum of Modern Art in New York. It's radical and amazing work, and of course, you had a lot to deal with. The Vietnam War, the starters, and probably finishes. You know, his Muhammad Ali cover is one of the greatest magazine covers all of all time. Best cover ever.
一个巨大的、醒目的图像，几乎没有文字或者完全没有文字。它们看起来几乎就像墙上的海报。现在，许多海报都成了纽约现代艺术博物馆的永久馆藏。这是激进而惊人的作品，当然，你必须应对很多事情。越南战争，那些明星，可能还有结局。你知道，他创作的穆罕默德·阿里封面是有史以来最伟大的杂志封面之一。史上最棒的封面。
If you've seen any of Lewis's covers or variations of his covers, it's probably this one. The cover is almost completely white with Muhammad Ali shirtless, pierced all over his body with arrows like a martyr. By refusing military service, there's a conscientious objector because of his new religion. He was sentenced to jail and then he was stripped of all his titles. And he was condemned as a draft doger and even a traitor. And so the idea of this cover was to suggest that he was a martyr to his religion. But the extraordinary thing about this image here is that the martyr they choose to model the
如果你见过洛伊斯的任何封面或他封面的变体，那很可能是这个。封面几乎完全是白色的，穆罕默德·阿里赤裸着上身，像殉道者一样，全身刺满了箭。由于拒绝服兵役，作为一个出于良心拒绝服兵役者，因为他的新宗教。他被判入狱，然后被剥夺了所有的头衔。他被谴责为逃兵甚至叛徒。所以这个封面的想法是暗示他是其宗教的殉道者。但这张图片最非凡的地方在于，他们选择作为照片模特的殉道者是一位基督教殉道者。具体来说，是安德烈·德尔·卡斯塔尼奥油画中描绘的圣塞巴斯蒂安。顺便说一句，圣塞巴斯蒂安也是体育的守护神。
photograph on was a Christian martyr. Specifically, Saint Sebastian as portrayed in oil paintings by Andrea del Castanio. Saint Sebastian, by the way, is also the patron saint of sports. Andy recounts the story as George Lois described it in his book. Mohammed Ali had to get on the phone with his religious leader, Elijah Mohammed. And Mohammed Ali had to explain the painting on which this photograph would be based in excruciating detail. Because Mohammed Ali was concerned about the propriety of using a Christian source for the portrayal of his martyrdom.
安迪讲述了乔治·洛伊斯在他的书中描述的故事。穆罕默德·阿里不得不与他的宗教领袖以利亚·穆罕默德通电话。穆罕默德·阿里不得不极其详细地解释这张照片将基于的画作。因为穆罕默德·阿里担心使用基督教素材来描绘他的殉难是否合适。
And finally, he put George Loewis, who is a non-practicing Greek Orthodox on the phone. After a lengthy theological discussion, Elijah Muhammad gave George Loewis his okay. George excelled and shot this portrait of a dayified man against the authorities. That's a hell of a lot of symbolism. Change your cover, change your life. And then came Cosmo. In 1965, Cosmo Politan ushered in the era of the cover line. The cover line, yes. Cover line, the word.
最后，他让不信教的希腊正教徒乔治·洛伊斯接了电话。经过一番漫长的神学讨论，以利亚·穆罕默德给了乔治·洛伊斯认可。乔治大显身手，拍摄了这幅神化的人对抗当局的肖像。这包含了一大堆象征意义。改变你的封面，改变你的人生。然后《时尚cosmo》出现了。1965年，《时尚cosmo》迎来了封面语时代。封面语，是的。封面语，这个词。
26 sex positions, we must try this weekend. Cosmo Politan wasn't the first to use text on the cover. But they were the first to use it really provocatively. 26 text positions you must try this weekend. And they set the standard template for what a new stand magazine looks like today. Goal straight through the middle, Caroline's left and right is a traditional doughnut. Donut is not standard industry lingo or anything.
26个我们这个周末必须尝试的性爱姿势。《时尚cosmo》并不是第一本在封面使用文字的杂志。但他们是第一本以真正挑衅的方式使用文字的杂志。26个你这个周末必须尝试的性爱姿势。他们为今天的报摊杂志设定了标准模板。中间是目标，左右两边是卡罗琳，这是一个传统的甜甜圈。甜甜圈不是行业标准术语什么的。
It's not a widely used term, but it's the girl through the middle. You've got the tight range left on one side, the tight range right on the other side, the master's head across the top, perhaps a big line across the bottom. Covers focused on words after the 1960s. That's where the cabaline comes in. That's where you start making very explicit promises to readers. And you take the readers' trust in your brand that you can deliver them. Promises like... 14 things you can do tonight' trust in your brand that you can deliver them. Promises like... 14 things you can do tonight that will save your marriage.
它不是一个广泛使用的术语，但它是中间的女孩。你有一侧的左侧紧密排列，另一侧的右侧紧密排列，跨越顶部的标题，也许底部还有一条大大的标题。1960年代之后，封面开始关注文字。这就是封面语的由来。也就是从这里开始，你开始对读者做出非常明确的承诺。你利用读者对你品牌的信任，相信你能兑现承诺。诸如……今晚你可以做的14件事，这些事可以拯救你的婚姻。
Or... 547 style ideas. 621 ways to get the most out of your look. Seven easy ways to be stressed. Hook them in with the cover lines, located very strategically. There's tremendous debate amongst editors and art directors as to how to maximize the value of the key pieces of real estate of a magazine for uncover. And these key pieces of real estate, very depending on the kind of magazine, celebrity
或者……547个时尚创意。621种充分利用你的造型的方法。缓解压力的七个简单方法。用经过精心战略布局的封面语吸引他们。编辑和艺术总监之间关于如何最大化杂志封面上黄金地段价值的争论非常激烈。而这些黄金地段因杂志类型而异，名人
weeklies always have their big cover lines splashed across the middle and it's yellow. It's always just it's yellow. Because yellow pops on new stand and you know it's got a very high color value, a very low tonal value. In fact the whole weekly market relies on yellow. If you look at us weekly people, life and style in touch actually that's not true. Life and style have taken the yellow special way
周刊总是把他们的大封面语横跨在中间，而且是黄色的。它总是——就是黄色。因为黄色在报摊上很显眼，你知道它的色彩价值很高，色调价值很低。事实上，整个周刊市场都依赖黄色。如果你看看《美国周刊》、《人物》、《生活与时尚》、《In Touch》，其实并非如此。1《生活与时尚》以特殊的方式采用了黄色，现在字体变成了白色，因为他们试图将自己塑造成一个稍微更具时尚导向的名人新闻周刊。
and now the type is now just white as they're trying to present themselves as a slightly more fashion orientated celebrity news weekly. And for the more lifestyle oriented, the location of the most captivating cover lines is the so-called hotspot. The hotspot immediately underneath the logo on the left-hand side. Or the right-hand side. Well, it depends on which country you're in. Much of this has to do with the way in which magazines are racked in the stands.
对于更偏向生活方式的杂志来说，最吸引人的封面语的位置就是所谓的“热点”。热点位于标志正下方左侧。或者右侧。好吧，这取决于你在哪个国家。这在很大程度上与杂志在书架上的摆放方式有关。
Magazines are very much designed around their racks. Here in the UK, a lot of magazines are shuffled. Only the left edge is revealed. So in England, you get most of your headlines on the left side or the leading left edge. British invasion, style from across the pond. Whereas in the USA, then there are you have a waterfall presentation
杂志的设计在很大程度上是为了适应它们的书架。在英国，很多杂志都是错开摆放的。只有左边缘露出来。所以在英国，你的大部分标题都在左侧或突出的左边缘。英国入侵，来自大洋彼岸的风格。而在美国，你则采用瀑布式的展示方式，
where you only see the top third. So we stick our best cover lines as high and close to the logo as we can on either side. US publications have many more cover lines than those in the UK. And that's purely because of the way in which they stack to retail. So magazines that don't rely on newsstand sales look very different from magazines that do. Titles like the Atlantic Bloomberg, Time, the New Yorker, these mostly function on subscriber
你只能看到上面三分之一。所以我们会把最好的封面语贴得尽可能高，贴在两边尽可能靠近标志的地方。美国刊物的封面语比英国的要多得多。这纯粹是因为它们零售时的堆叠方式。因此，不依赖报摊销量的杂志与依赖报摊销量的杂志看起来非常不同。诸如《大西洋月刊》、《彭博商业周刊》、《时代周刊》、《纽约客》等刊物，这些主要依靠订阅模式运营。
models. News-oriented magazines don't use the hotspots the same extent because they're not dependent on newsstandsile. They are a little more lowest-esque big photographs and pictures with not as much text. New Yorker covers Harkin' Back to a pre-1960s illustration model. Except when you encounter the New Yorker on the newsstand, in which case there's a little flap on the leading left edge with a list of contents.
新闻类杂志没有在相同程度上使用热点，因为它们不依赖报摊销售。它们更偏向于洛伊斯式的巨大照片和图片，文字没有那么多。《纽约客》的封面沿用了20世纪60年代之前的插图模式。除非你在报摊上看到《纽约客》，这种情况下，突出的左边缘会有一个小折页，上面列出了目录。
Finally, our guide to what readers want. Big pictures by themselves just don't sell like they used to. It's about volume of content. Magazine's are expensive on Newstand. There's a real job in reassuring readers that there's plenty to read inside. Hence the illegible cornucopia of cover lines on Esquire today. Yeah, okay, let's have a look. Esquer 2013.
最后，我们带你了解读者想要什么。单纯的大图片已经不像过去那样好卖了。关键在于内容的丰富度。杂志在报摊上价格不菲。真正要做的是让读者放心，里面有很多东西可读。因此，今天的《时尚先生》上才会有那些难以辨认的密密麻麻的封面语。是的，好吧，我们来看一看。《时尚先生》2013年刊。
Yeah, there's a very foxy picture here of Megan Fox. Check this. Now I like this cover. I like this cover by the fact that you can barely read the cover lines. They're so tiny. They're just saying, relax guys, there's loads of stuff in here. That design is the work of David Kirk-Rido. Learn how this old publication got a fresh new look. My name is David Kirk-Rido and I'm the design director for Esquire Magazine.
是的，这里有一张梅根·福克斯的非常迷人的照片。看看这个。现在我喜欢这个封面。尽管你几乎看不清封面语，但我还是喜欢这个封面。它们太小了。它们只是在说，伙计们，放松点，这里面有很多东西。这个设计是大卫·柯克兰里多的作品。了解这份老牌刊物如何焕然一新。我叫大卫·柯克兰里多，我是《时尚先生》杂志的设计总监。
The guy behind today's Esquire covers, which look nothing like Lois'. I'm responsible for the look of the magazine from Cover to Cover. My job is to pick photographers, pick all the images, pick the typography, pick the size of the typography, pick the color of the typography. The key word here is typography. My choice in typography definitely sets the tone for the covers without a doubt. Curcurrito's style is loaded with words. You design cover magazine, express.
那个打造当今《时尚先生》封面的人，这些封面看起来一点也不像洛伊斯的风格。我负责杂志从封面到封里的外观。我的工作是挑选摄影师、挑选所有的图片、挑选字体、挑选字体大小、挑选字体的颜色。这里的关键词是字体。毫无疑问，我对字体的选择绝对为封面定下了基调。柯克兰里多的风格充满了文字。你设计封面杂志，表达。
So overloaded that it explodes the doughnut. Cover everyone's life. Reader, secrets dial. Text is all over the cover in front of the celebrity. Behind the celebrity, handwritten, scrolled on the sides. Much of it, just completely illegible. A lot of text, yes, in the sense that there's an overwhelming
文字多到让甜甜圈爆炸。封面关乎每个人的生活。读者，秘密拨号。文字遍布整个封面，在名人前面，在名人后面，手写的，在两侧滚动。其中大部分，简直完全无法辨认。大量的文字，是的，因为文字多到压倒一切，
amount of text to illustrate that we have a ton of material inside the magazine. So much material that we can't possibly show it all to you on the cover even though we'll try. The text and the image, we've ended out of each other in such a way that the words almost become the image. What we've been doing is kind of overwhelming your senses with both the photography and the typography combined together.
用以说明杂志内部有大量的材料。材料多到我们无法在封面上向你全部展示，尽管我们会尽力尝试。文字和图像，我们以这样一种方式将它们交织在一起，以至于文字几乎变成了图像。我们一直在做的是，用摄影和排版相结合的方式来压倒你的感官。
It's been a radical kind of thing on the newsstand. And this is S-squares way of standing out from all the other magazines on the rack, but they don't stand out in the same way Lois' covers did in the 60s. We're a little more formulaic, but, yeah, we don't have the ability to do exactly what he did back in the day
这在报摊上是一种激进的做法。这也是《时尚先生》在书架上从所有其他杂志中脱颖而出的一种方式，但它们的脱颖而出方式并不像洛伊斯在60年代的封面那样。我们更公式化一点，但是，是的，我们没有能力完全做到他当年做的那样，
if that's making any sense. It's hard to replicate designs from the 60s because the audience is not from the 60s. I think people are less shocked today than they were in the past. I think it's much harder to shock people. I think we've become so desensitized to imagery that is really hard, but it can still be done.
如果这说得通的话。很难复制60年代的设计，因为受众已经不是60年代的受众了。我认为今天的人们不像过去那样容易感到震惊了。我认为要震惊人们要困难得多。我认为我们对图像已经变得如此麻木，以至于真的很困难，但它仍然可以做到。
I don't know. What's shocking now? Kim Kardashian and Kanye West.? Kim Kardashian and Kanye West. So Kim Kardashian and Kanye West, it is celebrity sell. You know, celebrity nine out of 10 times. I mean, we've been with that model for a really long time. Lois is not so certain that this is the way to get attention. Magazine's have always played its safe quote and quote by showing a famous person. Oh,
我不知道。现在有什么是令人震惊的？金·卡戴珊和坎耶·韦斯特？金·卡戴珊和坎耶·韦斯特。所以金·卡戴珊和坎耶·韦斯特，这就是名人效应。你知道，十有八九都是名人。我的意思是，我们采用这种模式已经很长时间了。洛伊斯并不那么确定这就是吸引眼球的方法。杂志一直是通过展示名人来打安全牌，所谓的安全牌。哦，
wow, that's going to touch people, right? And that kind of works if you're only, you have to be the only magazine in the world, but there's 150 magazines trying to choose to study your flavor amongst each month. George Lois is not amused. What these balloons have done before, since, you know, when everybody's done is, I mean, look, you don't have to know what you think about magazines or about anything.
哇，这会触动人们，对吧？如果你是世界上唯一的杂志，这种方法确实有点用，但每个月有150本杂志都在试图争取让你品尝它们的风味。乔治·洛伊斯并不觉得好笑。这些家伙以前做过的，自从，你知道的，当所有人都这么做的时候，我的意思是，看，你不需要知道你对杂志或任何事情有什么看法。
Only have to do it, have a pair of eyes. You go to a new stand and you take the glance at them. They will be incredibly inspired by me. And they work sucks. Infer George Lois, the solution is George Lois. I mean, at the station, look like my club is. But according to David Cercorito, there's a reason they don't. There are certain rules to to putting a
你只需要做一件事，长了一双眼睛。你去报摊看一眼。你会受到我的极大启发。他们的作品糟透了。对于乔治·洛伊斯来说，解决办法就是乔治·洛伊斯。我的意思是，在电台里，看起来像我的俱乐部。但根据大卫·柯克兰里多的说法，它们不这样做的原因是有原因的。制作一本杂志封面有一些既定的规则。
magazine cover together. You know, you want your logo at the top, a picture of a celebrity looking directly into the camera. You want to put your most important cover line, your words on the upper left hand side and the upper right hand
你知道，你希望你的标志在顶部，一张名人直视镜头的照片。你希望把你最重要的封面语、你的文字放在左上角和右上角。
side. And and to be quite honest, you know, when everybody follows the same set of rules, everybody looks the same. Kirkorito is messed with the standard layout, but he mostly sticks to the formula. Because this formula works. Or it has been working for a long time. The fact remains right now is that people are not buying
而且，说实话，你知道，当每个人都遵循同一套规则时，每个人看起来都一样。柯克兰里多打破了标准的版式，但他大多还是坚持这个公式。因为这个公式管用。或者说它已经管用很长时间了。事实依然是，现在人们不像以前那样去报摊买杂志了。他们真的不去了。
a new standard like they're used to. They really aren't. You know, magazine sales, a new standard falling. You know, people are no longer in the habit or even have the need to wander into a news agent on a random basis and just pick up a magazine. They'll click on a magazine. You know, George, I've no doubt when he's been on your radio show, he would be saying that all you have to do is put a really ass tearing idea out there on a great photograph
你知道，杂志在报摊上的销量正在下降。你知道，人们不再有习惯，甚至不需要偶尔随兴走进一家报刊亭随便买一本杂志。他们会点击一本杂志。你知道，乔治，毫无疑问，当他上你的广播节目时，他会说你只需要把一个非常震撼的想法和一个伟大的照片推出去，然后把人们惊艳得下巴都要掉下来，一切都会没事的。
and really shock the socks off people and everything will be okay. Yeah, that's pretty much exactly what he said. When you look at a magazine from 20 feet away, it should knock you on your ass. It's the same color. I mean, you know, with Infrasnac clonies, it's the wannabe stars, it's star of the service center. And they were all surrounded with five or six or seven or eight or nine ten blurbs, you know, unreadable blurbs.
是的，这几乎就是他说的。当你从20英尺外看一本杂志时，它应该能把你惊得一屁股坐到地上。这是同一种颜色。我的意思是，你知道的，对于时尚辣妹来说，那是想成名的明星，是服务中心的明星。它们周围都环绕着五、六、七、八、九、十个简短的宣传文案，你知道的，看不清的宣传文案。
But it also was terrible about the magazines, because the content of the magazine first or the layout and the design of every magazine these days Every page looks like a page from the internet. It's jammed. It's jammed with what young people think is information. It's a chick. There's a white space. It's still taking a 19-minute open in the water, shooting at no place, you're trying to stop agent. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, Sam Greenspan, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KLW in San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arxon, a brilliant architecture firm that takes special pride in their collaborative
但这也正是这些杂志糟糕的地方，因为杂志的内容首先是排版，如今每本杂志的设计。每一页看起来都像互联网上的一页。它塞满了东西。它塞满了年轻人认为是信息的东西。这是一个小鸡。这里有一片空白。它仍然是在水中打开19分钟，在没有地方的地方拍摄，你试图阻止经纪人。本周的“99%隐形”由埃弗里·特勒曼、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KLW的项目，制作于Arxon的办公室，Arxon是一家杰出的建筑事务所，以其位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的协作方法而自豪。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并给它点赞。我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@Samlistens，埃弗里是@Truffleman，但如果你有兴趣收听这个节目的前100集，每一集都是一颗打磨精美、小巧的广播故事宝石。请访问99pi.org。今天在播放。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
approach located in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, Avery tweets at Truffleman, but if you're interested in listening to the first 100 episodes of this program, each one of polished little gem of a radio story. Go to 99pi.org. Laying an ontop today. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。您可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞本节目。我在 Twitter 上发推文的账号是 Roman Mars，Sam 的账号是 Sam listens，Avery 的账号是 Truffleman。如果您有兴趣收听本节目的前 100 期节目，每一期都是一颗打磨精美的广播故事小宝石，请访问 99pi.org。今天的内容由 Radio Tapio 呈现，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。